so as you might have noticed by now I
love to make really like uh childish and
dirty jokes but sometimes I like to
offset that by inviting some of my
smarter wiser friends to come and say
something meaningful for a segment we
like to call profound
profane uh so say hello once again to my
friend David wolf everybody David wol is
here let now
good to see good to see you uh please
they have had it can we make it a little
bit more profound in
here oh I've felt surges of energy and
well-being that have caused me to want
to live you know sometimes somewhere we
start to check out
subconsciously all the pain the stress
the emotional turmoil and so when you
feel good all all the time you can
actually get into a state where you want
to live fully and get rid of
subconscious death
urges uh uh bugs get
horny you just never think about that
bugs bugs get horny sometimes it's crazy
think about a grasshopper somewhere just
like
who take a look at
Janette my bug dick is
hard you are what you eat the quality of
your food increases the quantity of your
energy the subtle energy of your food
can affect your mind try eating the best
food
ever someone's a
donut you know who you are someone out
there was like
glazed you vix
him